c'est l'heure de la vidéo de bilan ou
bilan glané bonne année à tous déjà pour
l'année qui a commencé pour 2020 bonne
année j'ai pas tous vos voeux se
réaliseront que vous allez emmener vos
rêves le plus haut possible faire tout
ce que vous souhaitiez tout ce qui vous
tient à coeur et on est tous vos projets
bien évidemment le plus loin le plus
haut le bonheur l'amour la réussite le
package complet pour 2020 première chose
c'est faire un petit récap de 2019 parce
que si on va regarder devant regarder ce
qui va arriver faut déjà acheté un petit
coup d'oeil à ce qui s'est passé ce
qu'on a réussi ce qu'on n'a pas réussi
non pas pour prendre de bonnes
résolutions parce qu'une fois de plus
les bonnes résolutions et moi ça fait
deux ça tient un jour deux jours mais au
bout d'un moment ça c'est rod y en a
plus ça marche plus non l'idée c'est
plutôt de se dire ok qu'est ce que j'ai
réussi en 2019 quels objectifs je
m'étais fixé début 2019
et au final ce que j'ai réussi à
atteindre ses objectifs parce que j'ai
réussi à les droites au but sans parler
de foot
est ce que j'ai réussi à aller là où je
voulais alors quand je regarde en
arrière je regarde la vidéo que j'ai
fait pour début 2019
eh bien j'avais plusieurs objectifs le
premier objectif c'était un objectif lié
à la communauté faut savoir que fin 2010
8 j'ai passé la barre fatidique des 100
mille abonnés et je vous est fixé un
objectif complètement dingue pour fin
2010 note je veux que au 31 décembre
on est atteint le truc complètement
dingue de 500 mille abonnés autant vous
dire qu'on n'y est pas du tout là on
doit une 251 me les quelque 750 2000 the
path of bêtise j'ai pas regardé
récemment les chiffres on en est là
c'est super bien franchement c'est
génial on a fait plus de doublé en un an
c'est vraiment super je suis vraiment
hyper content c'est vrai que j'aurais
espéré plus non pas que je sois déçu je
suis super content de ce qui aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment génial fait que vous
auriez tout cela tous présents en
répondant présent à chaque fois c'est
vraiment génial mais je sais pas
pourquoi tu t'es fixé ce pari un peu fou
ne rien manquer on y va on carbure on a
fait plus de cent mille abonnés en un an
maintenant on en peut d'après on va
faire carrément 400 mille abonnés plus
bon ok c'est un peu délirant pourquoi
pas on verra ce qui arrivera fin 2020 je
me fixe pas du tout objectif pour 2020
en termes de
volume d'abonnés il pas bien vous allez
être temps vous allez temps non vous
êtes toujours les bienvenues plus on est
de fous plus on rit ya plein de projets
meilleur plein de choses qui vont
arriver en 2020 je vous le dis juste
après ou fuit les objectifs d'aller voir
ses hommes à ces cons au final ce qui va
se passer
donc le premier objectif de 500 mille
abonnés ça c'est loupé je m'étais fixé
un autre objectif en début d'année
j'avais voulu lancer une chaîne l'a fait
quasiment la même chose mais en anglais
lancé match nul est le côté ski shop in
english shields died ac boys band music
métal festival cold hellfest il friends
you have to be placed in june in very
very own doit y avoir quelque chose
comme peut-être huit vidéos vous êtes
plus de 1000 abonnés sur la chaîne us
c'est très cool mais malheureusement je
me suis rapidement rendu compte que tout
seul on va voir ma chaîne principale
plus la chaîne us
je multiplie le temps de travail x 1.5
et au bout d'un moment on va pas dormir
la nuit ça passe il plus donc j'ai
précision de mettre ça en stand by à
voir plus tard probablement en 2020
alors ya eu d'autres projets qui sont
arrivés en cours d'année d'autres idées
qui me soit arrivée dans la tête
notamment le fait de faire un forum je
vous donne mon avis c'est le premier
point mais je suis que vous vous avez
aussi plein de compétences pleins de
connaissances c'était vachement bien de
pouvoir les mettre en commun pour
discuter et pas forcément sous chaque
vidéo et pourquoi pas au sein d'un même
endroit et notamment l'idée du forum est
arrivé là dessus alors pour l'instant
c'est toujours dans les tuyaux c'est
toujours un petit peu en stand by pour
manque de temps je pense qu'il va
arriver en 2020 je peux pas vous donner
de date précise
c'est un projet de 2019 que je décale
tout doucement jusqu'en 2020 on verra ce
qui arrivera ce moment là il ya un autre
point que j'ai pas très bien réussi en
2009 et je suis pas hyper hyper
satisfait de moi c'est la partie de même
que oj simpson c'est l'espace membre
quand vous cliquer sur s'abonner sous la
chaîne qui est quelque part par ici ou
par ici je sais jamais si je m'engage
dans la vidéo à l'écran de paris je vais
dire que c'est ici je suis pas sûr mais
je veux dire que ça ici le petit bouton
rouge vous cliquer sur s'abonner vous
savez il ya trois paliers
il ya un premier palier qui vous permet
d'être membre vous avez les émoticônes
vous avez le petit badge donc ça c'est
le premier palier vous avez un deuxième
palier vous choisissez la ligne
éditoriale vous choisissez les prochains
produits qui vont être testés ça c'est
le deuxième palier puis un troisième
palier dans lequel vous avez des vidéos
coulisses le truc c'est que une fois de
plus j'ai je pense que j'ai eu les yeux
plus gros que le ventre et j'ai pas
réussi à produire des vidéos coulisses
et c'est vraiment un truc qui m'embête
parce que c'est le palier
plus cher vous avez été nombreux à venir
derrière les vidéos sont pareillement
donc ça je vous regrette vraiment je
pense que je vais supprimer ce palier et
parce que je me rends compte qu'en fait
je manque vraiment en tout seul pour
aujourd'hui faire tout ça et pourtant
c'est pas les idées qui manquent pour
vous apporter cette vidéo coulisses ya
des choses à raconter
mais je m'en sors pas tout seul donc je
vais revoir ça leur meublé je suis
vraiment désolé et je présente toutes
mes excuses à tous ceux qui ont pris ce
palier là parce que malheureusement non
je m'en sors pas je n'arrive pas et ça
ça bloque d'où l'idée effectivement en
2020 et bien de doubler l'effectif de
l'entreprise pour l'instant je suis seul
donc on va passer de 1 à 2 ça ça va
arriver d'ici quelques mois je vous
expliquerai ça dans quelques temps je
vais recruter un monteur ou une menteuse
pour venir travailler avec moi pour
monter toutes les vidéos pour développer
tout ça ça permettra de dégager du temps
tous ces projets annexes et croyez m'en
plus sur la plein d'autres qui vont
arriver l'année prochaine dont je vous
parlerai en cours d'année pour l'instant
ça reste encore secret donc ça c'est
vraiment cool c'est pas un objectif
c'est chose qui va arriver très
clairement très bientôt je suis en train
de bosser sur les phases de recrutement
dont il va y avoir un moteur ou une
menteuse cela revient nous rejoindre
pour travailler directement avec moi
donc ça je vous en reparle dans quelques
temps il ya un autre que je vais
modifier sans qu'elle vous avez été
nombreux en fait a critiqué m bien ok le
générique de 7 cette année on n'aime pas
on n'aime pas le générique pour tout ça
ne correspond pas on s'y retrouve pas on
n'aime pas trop alors certains c'est la
musique de ces les planches ou pas je
pense que ça ne marche pas c'est
l'ambiance générale et elle vous ai pas
beaucoup je me suis dit au lieu de
refaire un générique je fais un tout qui
complètement différents jeux carrément
enlever le générique on va supprimer
gignac alors vous avez peut-être encore
de 2,3 vidéo en début d'année avec le
générique parce que c'est des choses que
j'ai tourné il ya pas longtemps et qui
vont être diffusés là mais sinon plus
générique je vais bosser différemment
l'écriture des vidéos l'idée pour
moisson 2020 si vous voulez ça va être
des changements réguliers des
améliorations régulières alors
effectivement il fait travailler
quelqu'un qui va être là pour le montage
ça va permettre de modifier tous ces
points corriger tous ces propos comme ça
ça va être cool parce que ça permet
d'aller plus loin de pousser sur le
montage de bosser sur le storytelling
les gars plein de choses qui vont
évoluer
donc ça vous le verrez début 2010 ne
pourront partir à vegas d'ici quelques
jours je vous emmener avec moi
la semaine prochaine on sera à las vegas
ensemble eh bien je vais essayer de
retravailler un petit peu le le
storytelling par les choses un peu
différemment
il va y avoir des évolutions toute
l'année mais jeudi
grosse évolution majeure plus générique
on va s'y de voir les choses un petit
peu différemment pendant du temps je
confirme qu'on me dit régulièrement
commentaires croyez moi les commentaires
jalil à petit je réponds pas forcément
par manque de temps je les lis jette un
coup d'oeil donc dites moi ce que vous
en pensez en blanc commentaire et qu'est
ce que vous souhaiteriez voir et quelles
sont vos idées notamment par rapport à
tout ce changement sur 2020 ça c'est un
petit peu la forme évasée par le fonds
qui va évoluer aussi aujourd'hui le
socle de la chaîne je dirais sont des
tests
il ya beaucoup de tests de smartphones
des ordinateurs des montres des
tablettes
il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
produits mais je me suis dit ok là
textes sont effectivement de les
produits mais pas que ce sont 6 plein de
belles histoires entre la tech et nous
comment ces objets vivent à travers nous
qu'est-ce qui se passe donc il va y
avoir plein de nouveaux formats de
vidéos qui vont arriver dans le courant
de l'année 2020 on regardera ça aussi
pas forcément tout de suite qu'on peut
tenter les choses se mettent en place
mais il va y avoir aussi toute une
évolution de ce côté là elle compterait
une fois de plus sur vous pour dire ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
et si dès maintenant vous avez des
attentes si oui quelles sont-elles alesi
marque et matous sans commentaire on
sera ça il y avait eu d'ailleurs un
format qui s'est lancé dans le deuxième
semestre 2010 9
ce sont les faq eu quelques effets qu il
y en aura d'autres et que je vous ferais
ça vegas la prochaine fois vous répondre
à toutes vos questions à toutes vos
interrogations alors l'année 2009 a été
riche en voyages
sans surprise il ya eu beaucoup de
surprises en 2019 j'ai jamais autant
voyagé toute ma vie très honnêtement je
crois je peux pas vous dire il ya eu new
york 3 fois las vegas hawaï une
régulièrement elle londres peut-être
quatre ou cinq fois lisbonne je suis
allé en corée à séoul
il ya eu barcelone madrid li a eu
séville enfin pas très loin de séville
un peu mollement en france il ya une
chamonix une super aventure aussi de ce
côté-là faille beaucoup de voyages et je
pense que 2020 va être une année
complètement aussi incroyable je pense
qu'il va y avoir aussi plein de
surprises alors à laquelle joue pas il
ya deux choses que je sais qu'ils vont
arriver cette année il ya le crs parce
que je pars la semaine prochaine avec as
le fameux cs et le deuxième c'est le mwc
à barcelone je serai à barcelone c'est
le grand salon de la téléphonie mobile
j'ai donc vous relier toutes les grandes
nouveautés tech depuis vegas et toutes
les grandes nouveautés plec liés à la
téléphonie mobile depuis barcelone
et entretemps il va y avoir aussi
beaucoup de lancements beaucoup de
lancement de marques à droite à gauche
plein de nouveautés plein de voyages
auchan soit une année qui va être
extrêmement riche va se passer plein de
choses
et j'imagine même pas à quoi va
ressembler la chaîne fin 2020
du jour la grosse surprise si vous
voulez je sais pas que l'on vous devriez
vous dis pas ok je commence une nouvelle
année et je suis curieux de savoir à
quoi je vais ressembler à la fin de
l'année enfin je dise comment ça devrait
pas trop changer
mais à quoi va ressembler la vie et
quelles vont être les choses qui vont se
passer durant cette année commence à
avoir ma portée à titre personnel et
comment ça va évoluer ma chaîne ce que
je fais aujourd'hui c'est aussi mon
business
donc comment est-ce que les choses vont
évoluer comment ça va se structurer
j'aurais jamais cru lorsque j'ai
commencé à faire la première vidéo fin
2016 que je me retrouverais pouvoir 8 de
match et que vous soyez aussi nombreux
je puisse embaucher quelqu'un crée un
emploi
j'aurais jamais imaginé donc j'imagine
même pas ce qui va arriver pour fin
d'année 2020-2021 ça me paraît
complètement dingue mais je pense qu'il
va y avoir plein de belles choses qui
vont se passer
sur ce je vous souhaite de passer un
excellent début d'année j'espère que
tout s'est bien passé pour vouloir que
moi vos résolutions est ce que vous avez
soit des résolutions soient alors des
objectifs pour l'année quels sont-ils
quelles sont-elles vous marquez tout ça
en bas en commentaire et quant à moi je
vous embrasse
je demande et vous dès demain pour bell
évidemment continuer à parler tech des
gros bisous à des matches à eau